ce à aubenas bonjour en zoulou c'est au
swaziland que j'ai découvert cette
salutation qui me touche beaucoup parce
qu elle parce qu'elle parle au coeur
elle m'invite à être ici présent
totalement face à vous alors elle veut
dire je te vois ou plus exactement
nous te voyons mes ancêtres et moi et
donc ce soir vous existez à travers mon
regard et j'existe à travers votre
regard j'ai de la chance vu le nombre de
regarde sur moi ce soir
et la réponse à cette salutation c'est
si kona je suis là parce que c'est un
dialogue
vous voyez donc je vous propose si vous
le voulez de nous saluer à nouveau je
vous dise à aubenas et vous me répondez
si vous êtes là si caunes à sao bona ça
fait du bien de recevoir ça en plein
coeur c'est l'essentiel est invisible
pour les yeux
vous voyez ma liberté je ne peux pas
l'avoir tout seul je ne peux pas à
l'acquérir seule elle vient de vous
c'est un don c'est un don mutuel ma
liberté c'est être avec ma liberté je
l'acquiert en étant solidaire s'y
connaît je suis là il ya quelques années
j'étais à l'école supérieure de commerce
de paris je terminais mes études je vais
travailler pour une entreprise
et puis assez rapidement j'ai pas
retrouvé le sens que je cherchais je me
suis dit si je continue comme ça je
gagnerai bien ma vie j'aurai un statut
social mais c'était pas ce que je
recherchais donc j'ai démissionné sans
savoir ce que j'allais faire et s'en est
suivie une période d'ouverture aux
événements aux personnes et c'est là
qu'un ami qui devait partir travailler
dans l'humanitaire aux philippines m'a
dit qu'il renonçait à son poste parce
que sa femme enceinte voulait accoucher
en france et il m'a invité à postuler à
sa place c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai été
retenu et j'ai tout de suite été séduit
par la proche de cette ong qui vise les
plus vulnérables et qui vise à leur
permettent de se prendre en charge leur
donner envie de se prendre en charge et
leur donner les moyens de le faire c'est
comme ça qu'il y à 22 ans je suis arrivé
aux philippines à manille dix millions
d'habitants à l'époque 14 millions
maintenant une ville avec du béton
partout des embouteillages monstres des
bidonvilles à perte de vue
et dès le départ j'ai identifié les
zones dans laquelle j'allais implanté le
programme de microfinance pour lequel
j'avais été envoyée j'ai choisi des
bidonvilles en bordure de la baie de
manille en bordure de mer avec des
maisons sur pilotis vulnérables aux
cyclones et puis à l'intérieur des
maisons construites sur un tas d'ordures
une odeur très forte acres partout des
tables avec des jeux d'argent de
l'alcool et pourtant dans cet
environnement difficile
j'ai tout de suite été séduit séduit par
le coeur des gens des gens qui donnent
qui vive la solidarité
un exemple la première visite à une
famille que j'ai fait je les fait avec
deux contacts locaux et sans qu'on s'en
aperçoive
la maman a demandé à son petit garçon
d'aller chercher trois bouteilles de
coca à la boutique pour nous parce
qu'aux philippines il est impoli
d'offrir de l'eau un visiteur en
discutant avec elle je me suis rendu
compte que ces trois bouteilles de coca
représenter les trois quarts de son
revenu journalier les trois quarts de ce
qu'elle avait aujourd'hui pour nourrir
sa famille le don sans compter elle
n'avait pas donné de sont superflus mais
deux sont essentiels ainsi nous avons
appuyé des centaines de familles avec
mon équipe aux philippines ont les
appuyer à travers des prêts productif
fait des formations et les gens me
disaient souvent merci merci d'être là
merci d'avoir quitté chez toi pour
travailler avec nous dans le bidonville
et je leur répondais c'est moi qui vous
remercie parce que ce que vous
m'apportez est encore beaucoup plus
grand que ce que je vous apporte vous
m'apportez des choses qui vont rester
dans mon coeur
alors quelques années après vous savez
le virus m'avait été inoculés aux
philippines le bon virus et quelques
années après j'ai créé évaluation sud
qui est un cabinet de consultants et de
coach
spécialisés dans l'appui aux projets de
développement au projet de solidarité
internationale
c'est ainsi que j'interviens en amérique
en afrique en asie sur des thématiques
variées la prévention la délinquance les
violences faites aux femmes
l'appui à des coopératives l'insertion
de personnes vulnérables
la gestion des risques de catastrophes
naturelles et c est mon métier c'est
d'aider des gens engagés dans la
solidarité à mieux faire ce que eux ils
ont envie de faire
la mentalité du crabe
vous connaissez crabe mentalité c'est
aux philippines que j'ai découvert ça
parce que je travaillais en bordure de
mer dans des zones de pêche est l'une
des principales activités des femmes
était de revendre du poissons et des
crabes
alors quand un crabe veut sortir du
panier qu'est ce qu'il fait il monte et
tous les autres crabe monte sur lui avec
le poids tout le monde descend et tous
les crabes reste au fond du panier
quand je regarde l'actualité quand je
vois l'état du monde je me demande est
ce qu'on n'en est pas là cinq millions
de français souffrent d'isolement 36%
des français ne connaissent pas ou peu
leurs voisins vous voyez les guerres les
conflits des problèmes de développement
dans le monde
comment s'en sortir alors je suis marqué
à la fois par notre manque de solidarité
et par notre incroyable capacité et
facilité à construire un monde solidaire
pour peu qu'on s'en donne les moyens
alors à l'instar des trois bouteilles de
coca offert tout à l'heure j'ai envie de
vous offrir trois portraits des gens qui
m'ont marqué parce qu'il vive la
solidarité et qui montre qu'il est
possible de construire un monde
différent reka aînés au bangladesh
elle travaille depuis 25 ans aux
philippines dans l'éducation pour les
plus vulnérables
elle me marque par ses capacités de
médiatrice de paix de tisser du lien là
où a priori c'est difficile je me
souviens d'un de nos voyages au
bangladesh ont traversé l'un des bras
gigantesques du gange sur un ferry et
j'avais entamé la discussion
j'avais entamé la discussion avec un
homme qui s'avérait est un religieux
intolérants au bout de dix minutes le
j'en avais marre dont je suis allé
prendre l'air reka a pris le relais
quelle ne fut pas ma surprise 25 minutes
plus tard de voir que reka et sept
hommes discutaient ensemble et que son
ton avait changé son intonation avait
changé sa position avait changé reka
voilà c'est ça c'est cette capacité à
tisser du lien
même avec une personnes hostiles à la
transformer par son sourire deuxième
portrait paul haussmann gelé connu au
sierra leone j'allais écrire un projet
d'insertion pour des personnes en
situation de handicap et j'étais dans
une enceinte muré avec des personnes
qu'ils rampaient et des personnes qui se
déplaçait sur des fauteuils roulants
roulant
j'étais particulièrement mal à l'aise et
puis pour le semaine est arrivé avec son
sourire avec son regard lui même
handicapé est tout de suite je me suis
senti mieux et il m'a expliqué comment
il avait créé ce centre de formation
professionnelle pour des personnes
atteintes de la polio dans le monde
alors je vais demander pourquoi ces
hauts murs lisses pour empêcher qu'on
nous vole quand vous veulent quoi
empêcher qui est des voleurs qui
viennent nous prendre les fauteuils
roulants de personnes handicapées volet
des personnes handicapées les condamnés
à ramper sur le sol parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'autres moyens de se mouvoir
ça m'a profondément bouleversé
michael et agnès c'est un couple que
j'ai rencontrés aux philippines sur la
décharge de paille apte à lui travaille
dans la microfinance et elle est la
compagne est un réseau d'agents de santé
quand ils ont quitté les philippines ils
m'ont dit qu'ils allaient s'installer en
france durablement pour y vivre la
solidarité ou attrape à trappes dans une
ville connue pour ses barres de hlm
ces émeutes ces tensions entre
communautés oui c'est cette ville qu'ils
avaient choisie pour y vivre pendant
plusieurs décennies
j'étais totalement admiratif j'en serais
totalement incapable et michael
travaille aujourd'hui au dialogue
chrétien musulman agnès accompagnent des
personnes qui sont perdus dans la
société et michael et agnès vivent à
double titre la solidarité ils sont
acteurs de solidarité est bénéficiaire
de solidarité ils ont choisi il ya
quelques années de ne pas avoir de
salaire de vivre de dons de dons d'amis
ils ont tissé un réseau de parrains dans
le monde
j'en fait modestement parti et ça fait
30 ans qu'ils arrivent à vivre comme ça
de la solidarité
non sans moments de doute non sans
moment d'efforts et ça marche
des personnes comme rica comme paul
haussmann comme michael et agnès j'en
connais beaucoup à la réunion j'ai la
chance d'en l'accompagné suzel pour les
malades d'alzheimer williams dans la
prévention de la délinquance justin pour
les enfants orphelins à madagascar et
thérèse qui a 84 ans se bat contre les
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants et tant d'autres et cette
capacité d'être solidaire on l'a tous
regardé le mois dernier à la réunion il
ya eu la marée rose odyssée à douze
mille coureurs contre le cancer du sein
il ya eu le trail le france alzheimer
réunion il ya eu la semaine de
solidarité internationale
il ya eu la semaine de l'économie
sociale et solidaire il ya eu le
mouvement des familles solidaire des
concerts solidaires comme les acharnés
pays
les acharnés les [ __ ] pays vous
voyez au total ce sont plus de 20000
réunionnais qui se sont mobilisés pour
la solidarité
parce qu'il y a urgence et c'est la
réponse à la crise de mai 25 ans
d'expérience dans le développement et la
solidarité
je tire quatre enseignements le premier
c'est que la solidarité nous fait du
bien à nous pour commencer
noël approche noël est une période
difficile pour ceux qui sont seuls
j'ai eu l'occasion de vivre quelques
nouvelles seul à l'étranger et de voir
toutes ses promesses de bonheur familial
quand on est seul c'est dur et je me
rappelle quand je marchais dans les rues
de grandes villes et qui avait un
passant qui me regardait ça aubenas qui
faisait attention à moi qui me parlait
ou un commerçant qu'ils aient quelques
mots ça me faisait un bien fou ça me
rebooster sa me je me sentais appartenir
à nouveau à la grande famille humaine
il ya quelques années nous avons décidé
avec ma femme de fer de temps à autre
des noël solidaire en invitant des
personnes qui sont seules à la réunion
et quelle chaleur qu'elle joue à des
gens qui ne se connaissent pas vivent
ensemble partagent un moment unique
ensemble et je me demande parfois c'est
peut-être moi qui reçoit le plus la
solidarité elle me met en mouvement je
suis dans l'agir
du coup j'oublie mes préoccupations
j'oublie mes peurs je sors de moi je me
détache de moi pour aller vers l'autre
et être heureux c'est rendre les autres
heureux et savoir recevoir
deuxième enseignement c'est que la
solidarité ça fait du bien à la société
ça fait du bien un territoire vous savez
je crois que la société elle est là
quelque chose de mystérieux elle vient
de l'origine des temps depuis l'âge des
cavernes l'espèce humaine n'aurait sans
doute pas survécu
sans solidarité sans entraide seul
l'être humain était perdu et je me
souviens d'une communauté au cap vert
dans un milieu très aride
un peu comme la plaine des sables qui
après deux années de sécheresse était
sur le point de quitter cet endroit où
avait vécu leurs parents et leurs
grands-parents
et puis un leader quelqu'un sur place à
mobiliser la solidarité à l'intérieur de
la communauté et à l'extérieur de la
communauté
elle est restée sur place et j'ai eu
l'occasion de vivre une fête
communautaire là bas dans une maison là
oui sans électricité dans une maison qui
sentait l'odeur de lait de chèvre cahier
parce qu'il faisait du fromage de chèvre
une odeur rance j'ai obligé de sortir
assez souvent pour respirer au départ
est bien dans cette maison les enfants
danser avec les vieux qui dansait avec
les personnes les adultes et il y avait
une incroyable force de la communauté la
solidarité fait du bien à la société
troisième enseignement la solidarité
c'est pas utopique la société c'est de
l'économie c'est de l'emploi l'économie
sociale et solidaire se sont toutes les
entreprises qui pratiquent l'économie
différemment en redistribuant une partie
des richesses à la société aux personnes
et l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
un emploi sur huit en france aujourd'hui
c'est 10 % des richesses créées en
france
déjà 1 million 300 mille associations en
elles vont recruter 600 mille personnes
d'ici 2020 dans le monde c'est pareil la
coopération internationale l'aide au
développement
ses 140 milliards de dollars et la
réunion commence à se positionner sur ce
secteur
je fais partie du bureau d'une
association l'affectif qui fait la
promotion de consultants de la
coopération internationale à la réunion
et à madagascar quatrième enseignement
c'est que nous sommes prêts nous en
sommes capables de tisser un monde
nouveau
c'est la réponse à la crise et il ya
urgence
nous avons une société nouvelle à tisser
et nous pouvons aller vite
si nous sommes prêts à nous engager et
si nous voulons basculé il faut le faire
tous ensemble c'est l'invitation que je
vous fais est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
tisser un monde plus solidaire
c'est un peu timide est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à tisser un monde solidaire
assez fort et bien je vous prends au mot
albert camus disait la vraie générosité
envers le futur c'est de tout donner au
présent
oui j'en vois certains qui sont inquiets
là tout donner la clé de la jaguar de la
porsche le portefeuille non je veux pas
demandé voilà c'est pas pour maintenant
vous le ferez quand vous voudrez après
six volets voilà moi je veux vous ai
amené des pelote de fil pour tisser un
monde solidaire et donc je vous propose
ce soir de participer à un événement
unique à une création originale de
tisser dans cette salle maintenant un
monde plus solidaire à travers des
pilotes de file alors vous voyez je vous
propose d'en tourre est de faire un
petit noeud autour de vous autour de la
taille autour du bras voilà pas trop
serré voilà ne m'étais pas autour du cou
on sait jamais et puis c'est pelote vous
allez recevoir quand vous les recevez je
vous propose
je vous propose de vous attacher et de
voulait renvoyer les uns aux autres
alors voilà des pilotes de toutes les
couleurs voilà comme vous dans la salle
je vous pose de tisser quelque chose
d'unique
j'ai pas compris
vous pouvez vous lever si vous voulez ça
sera plus facile
voilà je propose de faire une création
unique ça vaudra sans doute les
créations des tivoli sur l'île de
mindanao où les créations des indiennes
au guatemala
et il ya mille manières d'exprimer sa
solidarité un regard un sourire un
chèque ya une urne à la sortie de manche
présente un pardon a donné un pardon à
recevoir aller vers quelqu'un vers qui
on n'irait pas spontanément
voilà voilà ça commence à se tisser
alors au fond là-bas ils ont pas encore
reçu de pelote là bas à 6 allez-y
allez-y branchez vous sur votre âme
d'enfant sur le prince qui est en vous
sur la princesse qui est en vous parce
que nous sommes tous princes et
princesses
ça vaut le voit plein de fils qui volent
multicolores chacun de nous est unique
alors vais juste prendre encore une
minute pour vite ceux qui sont pas ceux
qui sont pas encore raccordés ou qui
souhaitent se raccorder et la solidarité
c'est ça c'est être relié par un fil à
quelqu'un on a la même valeur on est au
même niveau
nou lé pas plus nou lé pa moin et chacun
une valeur infinie
la solidarité c'est construire un monde
où on a chacun la même valeur où il ya
plus de rapport de dominant à dominé
voilà alors vous voyez c'est facile de
créer du lien avec quelqu'un
si vous vous pouvez vous asseoir
vous pouvez vous asseoir
voilà si vous voulez vous asseoir voyez
c'est facile de tisser du lien avec
quelqu'un vous êtes mal si vous tirez
sur le fil la dette reliée à quelqu'un
que peut-être vous ne connaissiez pas
tout à l'heure il ya un lien qui s'est
créé mais c'est comme ça qu'on peut
créer un monde solidaire
alors je vous invite je vous invite à la
pause à vous engager si vous le voulez
apprendre 30 secondes pour dire bonjour
échangé quelques mots avec la personne
avec laquelle vous être liés regardez
bien qui vous est relié moi je vois
voilà regardez bien essayé de voir son
visage pour tout à l'heure à la pause ah
ouais voilà
eh ben je vous invite à prendre 30
secondes pour vous saluer et ben c'est
comme ça qu'on tisse un monde solidaire
si conages été là je ne suis plus là où
ça les calais